fue un día de la semana jaime y bernardo
tienen una tarea cocinar la cena para
toda la familia pero pueden elegir el
día en el que cocinarán el domingo en la
noche
jaime realizó la siguiente propuesta hay
que tirar este dado de seis caras si es
un uno consignaremos el lunes si es un
dos cocinas hemos en martes con un 3
será el miércoles el 4 será el jueves y
el 5 el viernes si obtenemos un 6 lo
volveremos a tirar hasta obtener un
número del 1 al 5 pero quien cocinará
papá siempre llega a casa alrededor de
las 5 si llega antes de las 5 en el día
que elegimos tu cocinar la cena
y vemos que está hablando jaime así que
antes de las cinco y déjame escribir eso
antes de las cinco la propuesta de jaime
es que antes
antes
de las 5
bernardo cocinar a cocinar a bernardo
nada
y si llega después de las 5 yo cocinaré
la cena así que a las 5 o después a las
5 hombres pues
a la 5 después jaime
jaime cocinar a jaime cocinar a abajo
esta una tabla de frecuencias que
muestra los tiempos de llegada del papa
a lo largo de este año
supón que la tabla representa las
probabilidades verdaderas de su papa
llegando antes y después de las 5 en
cada día es justa la propuesta de jaime
para decidir quién cocinar a la cena
pensemos en eso primero que nada todos
los días la propuesta de jaime la
propuesta en la tabla dice que
esencialmente que pueden cocinar desde
un lunes hasta un viernes así que será
un día de la semana porque no hay manera
de que sea un sábado o un domingo porque
si sale un 6 lo volverán a tirar hasta
obtener un número del 1 al 5 cuando
pensamos en esto parece como si cada día
tuviera un quinto de probabilidad puedes
decir un 20 por ciento de probabilidad
de ser elegido pero podrías decir
y no es más bien un sexto de
probabilidad de que uno de los días se
ha elegido la primera vez que se tiran
los dados
y eso es cierto para la primera vez pero
si obtenemos un 6 entonces seguiremos y
seguiremos tirando y tirando y tirando
los dados hasta que dejemos de obtener
el número 6 hasta ese momento será
cuando obtendremos algo que no sea un 6
y todos tienen un resultado igualmente
probable no hay favoritismo hacia un
lunes o hacia un viernes así que si
tiene 5 resultados igualmente probables
si tienes lunes
martes
miércoles
jueves y viernes
5 resultados igualmente probables y esos
son todos los posibles resultados
entonces cada uno tiene un 20%
entonces
cada uno
y una probabilidad
20% de suceder
y podemos dibujar un lindo esquema de
probabilidad para mostrar esto
que está bien tienen un sexto cada uno
tiene un sexto de probabilidad la
primera vez que se tiran los dados pero
luego tienen un sexto de probabilidad de
volverse a tirar y luego tienen un sexto
de probabilidad después de eso y luego
tendrás en esencia esta suma infinita
que vendrá a ser un 20
por ciento
para cada día la manera más fácil de
pensar en esto
uno de estos cinco resultados va a
suceder y todos son igualmente probables
por lo que cada uno tiene una
probabilidad del 20 por ciento pero eso
por sí mismo no responde a la pregunta
de si la propuesta de jaime es justa
porque si vemos esto antes de las 5
cuando bernardo tendría que cocinar
antes de las 5 este es el caso
ver
cuando bernardo tiene que cocinar y
después de las 5 esto es cuando
m
tiene que cocinar y si ves a través de
todos los días de la semana parece que
hay una probabilidad de 50/50 de que su
papá llegue antes de las 5 o después de
las 5 y las 5 después las 5 está
incluido aquí supongamos que lo están
parece que es un 50/50 a través de la
semana
para cada día parece que el lunes es
mucho más probable es mucho más probable
que jaime tenga que cocinar el martes es
más probable que bernardo tenga que
cocinar el miércoles es un poco más
probable que jaime tenga que cocinar
pero no hay tanta diferencia como en el
lunes el jueves es 4 veces más probable
que bernardo tenga que cocinar a que
jaime tenga que cocinar y el viernes es
un poco más probable que jaime tenga que
cocinar a que bernardo lo haga una
manera de pensar en esto
obtengamos la probabilidad de la
probabilidad de digamos de que bernardo
tenga que cocinar un determinado día
como sería eso así que veamos hay una
probabilidad de 20% hay una probabilidad
del 20 por ciento de que al tirar los
dados nos lleve al lunes no escribiré
como decimal así que es 0.2 y si estamos
lidiando con el lunes
entonces bernardo tiene tiene 520 abós
una probabilidad de 520 a vos de tener
que cocinar así que punto 2 por 5 sobre
20 que realmente es lo mismo
45 entre 20
luego hay un 20% de probabilidad de que
obtengamos un martes en martes bernardo
tiene una probabilidad de 15 sobre 20 de
tener que cocinar una probabilidad de
tres cuartos
cuartos el miércoles que también hay un
20 por ciento de probabilidad de tener
que cocinar en miércoles bernardo tiene
una probabilidad de 820 a vos de tener
que cocinar ese día así que 820 a vos es
lo mismo que dos quintos dos quintos y
luego el jueves otra vez tienen un 20%
de probabilidad de tener que cocinar el
jueves 16 20 a vos es la probabilidad de
que bernardo tenga que cocinar que es lo
mismo que cuatro quintos
finalmente en viernes donde una vez más
hay un 20% de probabilidad de que el
dado de que el sistema de tirar el dado
llegue a viernes aquí bernardo tiene 620
años de probabilidad de tener que
cocinar que es lo mismo que
sobre 10
y podemos factorizar el 20% aquí así que
el 0.2 va a ser
y cuarto
más
cuartos más dos quintos más cuatro
quintos más tres décimos más tres
décimos que va a ser igual a un cuarto
más tres cuartos va a ser igual a 12
quintos más cuatro quintos es igual a
seis
juntos
+ 3 decimos déjame escribir todo en
términos de decimos
así que diez décimos eso es uno más
doce decimos eso es seis puntos más tres
décimos nos lleva nos llega a 25 decimos
25 decimos que por supuesto es lo mismo
que cinco medios por lo que todo esto de
aquí se simplifica a
a 5 medios así que tenemos la
probabilidad de que bernardo tenga que
cocinar que bernardo tenga que cocinar
esta semana que bernardo tenga que
cocinar va a ser igual a 0.20 puntos por
5 medios por
5 sobre 2 cuánto será eso 0.2 es lo
mismo que
un quinto por cinco medios que será lo
mismo que un medio así que acabamos de
ver que bernardo tiene una probabilidad
de un medio de tener que cocinar en la
semana lo que significa que jaime tiene
una probabilidad de un medio de tener
que cocinar esa semana y hay un buen
este es un indicador bastante bueno de
que eso iba a pasar justo aquí hay un
50% de probabilidad de que pase antes de
las 5 de la tarde y hay un 50% de
probabilidad de que sea a las 5 o
después y en cada día dado hay una
probabilidad igual hay un 20% de
probabilidad en el día de cocinar por lo
que diría que la propuesta de jaime es
justa
la propuesta de jaime es una manera
justa de decidir quién cocinará y
también en qué día de la semana sera
cuál es la probabilidad de que el
miércoles sea elegido y bernardo cociné
en la cena
ya habíamos pensado ya habíamos pensado
en eso hay un 20% de probabilidad hay un
20% de probabilidad de que el miércoles
sea elegido
y bernardo tiene 12 kings o tiene una
probabilidad de 820 a vos de cocinar ese
día 8 20 a vos es lo mismo que 820 a vos
es lo mismo que dos quintos 8 dividido
entre 4 esos 20 dividido entre 4 y 5
así que 0.2 por dos quintos eso es igual
al 0.2 es
quinto por dos quintos
qué es lo mismo que esto es igual
2 sobre 25 y si quisiéramos escribirlo
en términos de un porcentaje o un
decimal
esto sería igual a 0 punto
0 punto y mejor cambiemos a esto será lo
mismo que 8 sobre
que es igual a una probabilidad pero 8%
por ciento la probabilidad de que se
elija el miércoles y de que bernardo
cocina en la cena es de 8%
0.08